[Music]
I'm up I'm up
you like that huh
nice ride nice
how much excuse me how much for the car
she's not for sale
good day sir
I lost everything that dog was a final
gift from my dying wife
Jonathan you got out once you dip so
much as a pinky back into this Pond you
may find something reaching out to pull
you back in it's personal where'd you
get that car what does it matter
it's not what you did son it's who you
did it to
nobody
but nobody
is John woke
[Music]
you working again no just sorting some
stuff out Tasker crew how many as mad as
you have
hey John
I thought I let myself in
you keep asking if I'm back
yeah I'm thinking I'm back
[Applause]
I'm not afraid of John Wick
no one's that good I thought
[Music]
oh good to see you again so soon Mr weak
I need him to do this task I'm not that
guy anymore
you're always that guy John I can't help
you you're not the rose if you don't do
this you know the consequences
foreign
week
the contract has gone International you
have no idea what's coming
get this man
a gun
you stabbed the devil in the back to him
this isn't Vengeance this is justice
thank you
[Applause]
you working afraid so whoever comes I'll
kill him
[Music]
I'll kill them all cool
I'll try and do the same
[Music]
foreign
you have no idea what's coming
Mr wet broke the rules
I trust you understand the repercussions
if he survives
John Wick excommunicano is now in effect
[Music]
you shouldn't be here laughs
nice suit
good to see you too
I need your help
after this we are less than even
There's No Escape for you
high table once your life
would you help set the mood for a new
guest let us begin
[Music]
our services still off limits to me what
do you need guns
lots of guns
you think you can take John Wick
you've got a nasty surprise coming
I'm looking forward to meeting you
for a long time
and so far you haven't disappointed
we can keep this up as long as you'd
like
with us only ends one way
all of this for what because of a puppy
wasn't just a puppy
saying goodbyes
you think your wife can hear you
no
the white ball
Maybe I'm Wrong
maybe not goodbye to you my trusted
friend
a new day is Dawning
new ideas no wounds no management we've
known each other since
[Music]
who is this the Marquis De gramo
challenge him to single combat with a
loose it's a way out
I don't sit at the table your family
does please pray for me
love
[Music]
man has to look his best when it's time
to get married
or buried I'm going to need a gun
goodbye my friend
[Music]
if you win
the table will honor its word
you'll have your freedom
that's the old laws only one can survive
failure to meet at sunrise
will result in execution
Last Words Winston just happened
I want you to find your peace but a good
death only comes after good life
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
[Music]